it is this stupid situation where you've
got 38 state
legalizing medical and then we have 17
with recreational and you have all these
businesses
and billions of dollars being generated
but it's federally illegal it's the
dumbest situation i've ever seen
that we can't do anything about i mean
it's so it's so ridiculous
chris walsh welcome to the show thank
you for having me on excited to talk
cannabis
what is someone with an mba doing
working in the cannabis industry
well i was finishing it when i got
involved back in 2011
and definitely got a lot of questions
about what the hell i was doing
um i was i was finishing my mba and was
had a background in journalism so i was
a business reporter and editor at
newspapers in the us and in south korea
uh so what is a person with an mba doing
you're seeing more and more of people
like me come in
but it's uh it's a massive business
opportunity and it's it's
in the us it's in canada it's in europe
it's in south america
it's all over the world now so i i'm in
it because
first and foremost it was a fascinating
industry that i wanted to be part of i
don't come from the campus culture
but from a business perspective i
thought there was a lot to like here
into helping develop a new industry and
also you know cannabis helps people in a
lot of ways so
it's not like we're making you know cups
or whatever you know like we're doing
something we're making a product
we're helping an industry that relies on
a product that's actually helping people
and that's important to me personally
too so a lot of
unique aspects about cannabis that lured
me into it
what makes the cannabis industry so
interesting
well i would say that the rapid speed at
which
cannabis has gained
support all over the place uh you know
this was something
even when we started uh that was really
taboo
still and so this again we started 2011
and even then it was like what is my
aunt who's a nun on the east coast going
to say and what is my dad a serious
political journalist going to say and so
you know what we've seen is that the
rapid acceptance of this industry has
has has been phenomenal way faster than
i thought
so there's just excitement around it
people are embracing it they're
accepting it
it's an industry that has come out of
the darkness very quickly it's existed
for a long time right but not in a legal
fashion
and people are interested in it it's
it's it's fun it's cool
and you know there's not a lot of
industries that offer this level of
excitement and opportunity
the people in it are different there's
great people there's um
not uh there's in some cases there's not
a lot of business sophistication which
is changing
but what you have this industry crop up
especially here in the us
where you know the average everyday
person could get involved
and that is changing you know but
initially
the regulations were really low the cost
to enter was low and so you had kind of
this
american dream type industry where you
didn't have to
you know have 15 years of experience or
have started three other companies or
have
a million dollars in funding to get
involved
so a lot of these are some of the
aspects about it and um
and just the massive video when you
bring this up at a party that you're
into it
that you're at um no one even over the
la ten years i've been in it
most people are not like oh i can't
believe you're doing that or they don't
like kind of
turn up their nose and walk away if
anything they're interested even if they
don't support it they're just interested
so for all these reasons i think it's
it's a really fun exciting industry it's
challenging though it's really hard it's
harder than anything i've ever done
but uh it's um
it changes so quickly right and and
first of all i'll just start with this
it's really
difficult to learn the industry because
in the us and this is a microcosm of
what we see internationally including in
europe
every state is handling this differently
and every city is handling it
differently and so
they use different terms and jargon and
they they view it differently
and there's different regulatory
structures there's no there's no
commonalities
so you just to learn about what the heck
is going on
and so you feel like you can hold your
own in a conversation even
at a base level takes a long it takes a
long time because just when you think
you got to figure it out there's some
whole other area of the industry you're
like oh
i didn't even know about this or it
worked that way
and so the the international industry is
that way too the global industry
you know um the uk is handling it
different from you know greece and
they're handling it different from
denmark and
all of them are handling different from
colombia and south america you know
so uh you have to really it's it's
constantly evolving it takes a long time
to get a handle on it
and um and then it changes and you don't
know how it's gonna change
you have no idea how it's gonna change
both in positive
immensely positive ways and also in in
negative ways that can hurt your
business uh and because you don't know
what to expect so these are the reasons
it's challenging
and i'll go back to what i said a minute
ago the people in the industry now are
different
and that's often a very good thing but
if you're used to regular business norms
and and
ways of uh conducting
business it's different here so that
takes a while too to learn
you know there's a lot of people who who
won't do business unless they know you
it's not like you can come in using all
this mba jargon right
and sell them on something they're going
to you know smack you and tell you to go
away
so there's just a lot of unique aspects
of it you once get accused of being an
fbi agent
at a an expo at some point because you
were the only guy there in a suit and
tie
um yes very very close uh when we first
started in 2011 i was doing research
trying to understand the industry myself
which is much different than it is now
but at the time it was only legal for
medical purposes
in colorado where we were based and and
some other states
still illegal you know federally then
and now um
so there was a lot of the people who
were forming businesses then
came from the cannabis culture they were
maybe growing in their basement
or buying and selling on the illicit
market
and so they didn't know if someone was
going to come in
we didn't know what the federal
government was going to do even though
it was legal in
in the states it was not um from from
the federal government and they were
operating businesses that you could find
on sea
on the streets they weren't underground
hidden and so i went to an industry
trade group
and yes i actually went to the bathroom
and there was a guy in there and
you know they're kind of awkward when
two dudes are kind of there
going to the bathroom and he's like you
know what you seem
you seem pretty cool but uh you're not
an fbi agent are you
and he really felt that i wasn't just to
ingest because they didn't know if this
meeting
of professionals in the industry was
going to get broken up and they'd be
hauled off to jail
that's that's the situation these people
started it
can you explain what on earth is going
on
when you have something that's legal at
the state level
but illegal at the federal level how
does that even work
i hey if anyone can answer that for me
please do because um i've been racking
my brain to figure it out over all these
years basically
the government just turns its head away
and says this is a low enforcement
priority and that's what really changed
the industry
is you know in 2011 2012 there had been
crackdowns because the government was
going in and raiding
dispensaries when you say the government
are they deploying is that the fbi
uh federal agents right in different
agencies and they were going in and
and there weren't regulations really
around the industry then the states
weren't
regulating it they were just people
saying hey it's legal in my state so i'm
going to open up a dispensary
or cultivation operation and i'm just
going to do this until someone says so
that it just built from that and
expanded and then there was crackdowns
by federal government agents and and
there was a point where after we started
where we almost got out of the industry
because we're like i don't know if it's
gonna make it as a real business
um but then the federal government
basically
um under obama said okay we're gonna
look the other way
this is gonna be a lower enforcement
priority they didn't say we're gonna
look the other way but they said look we
got a lot to deal with
so you know don't don't worry about this
especially if there's regulations behind
it that was the key
so all these states started regulating
the industry
and establishing you know this is what
you got to do you got to get a license
you got to operate under these um rules
and regulations and you got to be a
legit business when we started there
were
there were people on the corners you
know for their dispensary and they'd
have a big sign with a joint on it
they'd be spinning it around and
and you know pointing this way and you
know you're on major thoroughfares and
and there's kids and and and there were
billboards and that people didn't like
that
like the community didn't like that
lawmakers didn't like that so you have
this move
to start excuse me regulating the
industry and
i'm sorry and that really started making
it more acceptable
and so to get back to your point the
federal situation
it just developed on its own in all
these states
and it eventually reached a critical
mass and there were enough people that
supported it enough people involved
enough money coming in in taxes and
enough startup activity and job growth
that it just dominoed and snowballed and
then you had more states legalizing and
starting industries and more and the
federal government really at one you
know it got to the point where they
couldn't really do anything about it
and so they they didn't consider a
priority and with that
basically pathway forward by saying hey
we're not gonna this isn't gonna be a
top priority for us
the industry just ballooned and so it is
this stupid situation
where you've got 38 i think we just had
39th state
legalizing medical and then we have 17
with recreational plus our
you know the capital of our nation
washington dc has legalized both
and you have all these businesses and
billions of dollars being generated but
it's federally illegal it's a it's the
dumbest situation i've ever seen that we
can't do anything about i mean it's so
it's so ridiculous when you step back
and that's where your question was it's
like how
how does this gonna happen
was that the final word from the
government
was the final word from the government
this isn't a top priority
and there's been no other update since
then basically
um not really there was a modification
of the memo that basically
paved the way for the recreational
industry that that said if
if it's regulated if it's regulated the
adult use
recreational use it for anything you
want when that started cropping up
you know the government was like okay
kind of same thing we're not gonna
as long as the states are overseeing
this uh and there were some key
guidelines in there
and there's been comments on it along
the way under the trump administration
we weren't sure if there was gonna be a
crackdown
uh you know uh traditional long time
conservatives older generation is
usually you know against this
historically and has has come around but
still especially in washington dc
there's still a lot of resistance from
that group and so we didn't know what
trump was going to do his
his uh jeff sessions you know our top
kind of
law enforcement official he um it looked
like he might crack down but it never
occurred
so there really it's just this kind of
gray area but
what you're seeing is that it's so big
it's so accepted now
90 over 90 support for medical marijuana
legalization across the country whether
you're in the really conservative
anti-marijuana states
or in the more friendly ones and
recreational marijuana is above 60
percent
i mean this is a losing issue in general
so
um so yeah i mean there hasn't really
been we're just kind of people are just
moving forward and now there's been a
lot of moves federally to change the
laws
uh but they kind of they're working
their way through our our government
process
and and the resistance has kind of
blocked them and
so we don't know what's going to happen
we're in a good position now where there
could be federal change
because the you know the
centers of power in our government are
all controlled right now
through next year by the democrats and
they are
you know they have been pushing
marijuana so it's become a big topic
they're trying to get bills through
there's still resistance uh
it's only a matter of time it's like is
it a year or four years i don't know
but here's what i just want to point out
that it's interesting because people
look to the us and say oh this this
marijuana industry and they're the
leaders
and in a lot of cases the us is they're
the biggest right there's a lot of
innovation going
on here if you ever visit a store
there's all these array of products and
uh it's really cool to see but there's
over two dozen other countries that have
legalized
medical cannabis federally and some of
them have legalized recreational
so the us is actually way behind from
that policy standpoint
and so um it's just a weird dynamic all
around
what do you reckon is going to happen
with the uk can you imagine the uptight
brits over here gloomy skies cup of tea
and a
spliff on the morning i can i'm sure
that's already going on
uh in many cases as it is in every
country around the world
uh in terms of of the broader
legalization i mean
you know i have been surprised many
times
as i mentioned before you never know
what's going to happen right some of the
developments have been negative but a
lot of them are positive where we never
thought something momentous would occur
or to this level and uh and and i do
think
and by that i mean you've you've seen
countries you've seen states in the us
legalize
when they weren't even on the radar a
year before or there was there seemed to
be like no way
and i remember a couple years ago i was
doing a lot of our global
market research and traveling around to
europe and south america and other
other areas of the world as we expanded
globally i was speaking and learning
about these industries
and where they were at with the cannabis
discussion and everyone i talked to in
europe
said uk will be the last they'll be the
last
um and and they said no no people from
the uk people from other countries in
europe
uh said uk will be the last and you know
you know what happened is there was the
one case that got out there of
of a couple who had a daughter and she
needed she had seizures
and it did we've seen this play out in
in other areas including in the us
and this whole debate all of a sudden
out of nowhere arose around you know cbd
and and people started changing their
minds and then there were some
there were some moves there to loosen
laws around that
so i i do think this i would not put it
out of the question that it's five ten
years off or will never happen
um it can absolutely happen and
attitudes
all over the place are changing really
quickly
my impression whenever i go to america
is it's
bonkers how widespread the acceptance of
it is
now it seemed the same way as having a
beer would be
you know it there's no friction at all
as far as i can see
people do it on an afternoon because
it's saturday and we're watching
football or
we're going out for some food or
whatever it might be and um
yeah it's crazy i wonder i wonder how
much romance
is still attributed to it being a drug
as opposed to a drink or something
that's obviously legalized
because you still have that layer of um
federal scrupulousness right they're
looking at what's going on and you know
that there's still an
a tiny little one percent amount even if
you're in the most liberal state in all
of america
it's still kind of a bit illegal if the
wrong person at the wrong time saw it
there's still a law somewhere that says
no
i wonder how much that contributes to
kind of the romance
still of it being a bit of a counter
culture of it being something that's up
and coming
that's a great observation or question i
remember a couple years ago
i know someone who lives in the south
the southern part of the u.s
a very close person to me and
he said he came to colorado tried out
all the
you know marijuana stores and went to i
got him a tour of a grow and he's like
this is fantastic and he had used a long
time's life again i don't come from that
background of using heavily
but he did and it was like a kid in a
candy store when he came here and by the
time he
left he said you know i don't know if i
want this to come to my state
and i said why this should be this
should be what you're rooting for this
is your heaven
and he said it just feels like it's
going to be like everything else
and he and and so to your point there's
there are absolutely there's there's
resistance in in numerous ways
so i want to make sure we're clear that
you know there's there's people who are
against it morally there's people who
think
you know uh that are unsure there's
others who think it's gonna ruin
communities
um but there's also this contingent that
enjoyed and part of the fun of using
cannabis
was the counterculture aspect and how
you got it and the people you talked to
and smoked with and um and the type of
marijuana you were getting right even
though this is much higher quality and
better and it's packaged nicely and
there's all these products
some people say i just want that i just
want that really good
you know bud that i got and i'd roll
into a joint from the guy i know
yeah you know johnny fat bags on the
corner or whatever yeah johnny fat bags
there yeah
i like that name um yeah so
so uh you hit you hit the nail on the
head there are people like that and
there are others
who do not like how it's progressed into
um
more of a corporate mentality and and
that has been needed to push
legalization because
the general public doesn't want to see
the counterculture aspects
punk rockers stood up in front of
congress saying that we need
we need more dispensaries in our state
yeah or running stores without
regulations right
that are there's you people are afraid
to go in or they're you know whatever
and so there's definitely people who are
saying it's gone way too far
in the business corporate direction and
we're losing that counterculture element
and they are right they are absolutely
right now you can argue whether
whether that's a good thing or not but
the fact of the matter remains is it's
happening
and we the counterculture is actually
becoming
smaller and smaller a piece as the suits
as the business people come in
uh and start running this like every
other industry so i'm i'm concerned
about that too because
it needed to move along the spectrum
didn't need to move all the way this way
shouldn't be all the way over here it
should be in the middle
and that's what i like about the
industry is it's different and if it
does become like anything else
uh you know it's going to lose its
allure and unfortunately it's going to
block out
a lot of people for business
opportunities for careers
that uh you know that that might have
had an opportunity in the past
um because then you need a different
skill set and they're going to be
looking for you know
people from the mainstream corporate
world so a lot going on in this industry
a lot of changes and they're happening
quickly it really seems like that man it
doesn't surprise me either that it's
difficult to keep on top of
all of these different moving parts and
elements it was an industry before it
was a monetizable industry or at least
on scale
here's one of the things that i found
that was really fascinating i spent a
fair bit of time in la
over the last five years or so and going
down
hollywood boulevard you would see a 150
foot high
ignite poster or some other big
marijuana brand poster and what i
realized
or what i thought what i figured at the
time was that
when marijuana became legalized
recreationally
and you could advertise it as a
recreational product
what was essentially happening was that
the government or the state
was firing the starter pistol for
everybody
to just decide to press go right you
had similar amounts of technology that
people understood the industry
abilities to grow access to growers so
on and so forth
so what people needed to do was compete
based on marketing
because the products at the end of the
day were all going to be relatively
similar
but you had an industry that was ready
to go spinning its wheels as fast as it
could
launch control the button gets hit and
everybody goes so what i
noticed was you had mike tyson
you had dan bilzerian you had other
celebrities and
well-known influencers that were getting
involved very sort of at the
figureheads of companies right i
wondered how much of that
was companies just thinking right what
is the fastest way
that we can become the ubiquitous name
that when you say weed
you say this ignite or
mike tyson's ranch or whatever it might
be tyson ranch
um is that was that right is that what
kind of happened was it companies just
thinking right we need to capture as
much of the culture as possible
therefore who's the biggest loudest name
that we can get strap them to the front
of this rocket ship and then when the
government says go or when state says go
we have more clout and we have more eyes
on us
yeah and i would compare it to
traditional business in general
you know the use of celebrities that
resonate with your target customer
is widespread at least in the us in many
many ways
and it's a tried and true method uh that
companies use to build a brand and and
to get traction
and so as more uh
famous people or semi-famous you know
some of these people were famous like 30
years ago you know
and we're tied to the cannabis culture
like cheech and chong you know also
they're back
back at it uh but they they felt
comfortable attaching their names to
this and then it started to expand and
the companies yes to your point
are saying how do i how do i build a
brand that's different what's familiar
to my
target customer base right and in a lot
of cases
a lot of cases it's people who had
initially the first couple waves of this
were
more well-known people who had this
cannabis tie whether they're in movies
whether they smoke personally and
we're open about it whatever it was and
it's what you've seen more recently as
an um
an iteration of this and so now
companies
are getting former federal regulators
former politicians on the awards
yeah the former speaker of the house the
u.s house is on the board of a
cannabis company you also had
celebrities that
want had nothing to do with cannabis so
money talks right
money money money talks in this country
and so that
has helped bring more people into the
fold as it's becoming more normalized
but you know we had an event uh i think
i believe it was two years ago one of
our
business trade shows and uh we had gene
simmons the you know lead singer of kiss
and
and he because he was he was actually
signed up as the spokesperson kind of
brand ambassador for a cannabis company
he never used drugs in his life ever he
never even tried cannabis
but again money talks um so you've seen
another iteration
former politicians high up in in
washington dc former state politicians
and other people with brands and with
names
that aren't associated with cannabis
traditionally that have jumped in
and the companies are you're absolutely
right they're like how can i stand out
as i see this progressing down the road
and it becomes more of a bigger
national industry uh how am i going to
build my brand and that's one way
they're doing it
it's fascinating to look at as an
industry because
the barriers to entry are relatively low
as you've said
even if you want to become fairly
sophisticated it's not going to be as
hard
to make a range of edibles and vape pens
and pre-rolled
joints as it is to create an iphone or a
competitor to the iphone
also because this industry is just
starting now
there aren't these established players
you know how many iterations do
apple and samsung and huawei have on
creating electronics and you now need to
reverse engineer all the [ __ ] that
they've done for the last god knows how
many
years whereas with this it's it really
does feel like everyone's kind of
going at the same rate just how big is
the industry
well and just to address your first
point uh the us
is a just like europe it's a it's a
tapestry of different
you know communities and viewpoints and
and so what's the when you apply that to
the marijuana industry
california's industry is way different
than florida's and that's way different
than colorado's and that's way different
than new york's
emerging industry and um and so in some
cases the reason i bring that up is
in some cases states have tried to keep
the barriers low
and they've tried to say okay there's
going to be low application fees
uh we're going to you know have social
equity components that help people that
might not have the money that have been
traditionally marginalized there's a lot
of different
ways they're looking into these things
but there the trend has been that it's
getting harder and harder so those
barriers
are yes not to the level of creating an
iphone but
um it's also to the point where you
usually
in a lot of states now have to have a
million or two lined up
just to get started just to like get a
license
prove that you have the money to operate
an effective business
and then start your operation so yeah
that's i mean that's a barrier to entry
right
that's a big one uh and that's where
it's changing but again other states
it's a lot lower it just depends on
where you're looking so it's
it's all over the board did you watch
murder mountain
i haven't oh man you need to it's this
is this is your jam
this is completely about your german
it's on netflix it's a
fly on the wall documentary about a
bunch of different
you you need to watch it anyway and i've
heard about it i've just i've been so
busy keeping up with the changes the
cannabis industry i don't even have time
to watch things
precisely i understand but you see you
you see the
likelihood in in situations like that of
what's going on
just how these people these sort of
small time growers that used to be there
are no longer able to make it work
because they are being pushed out
they're having margins squeezed they're
having
particular stipulations put on with
regards to the
type of yield the size the quality
that's expected
certain um standards that they maybe
didn't used to have to meet
or were different as far as they wanted
to and
yeah i wonder whether it'll loop back
around and you'll end up with artisan
blends
you know kind of single
harvest grows from very particular
you know people that are coffee
aficionados are prepared to pay
for a very unique blend that's a little
bit more
specific and then you'd have the kind of
nespresso
instant coffee pod for the the normal
day-to-day user
yeah you're absolutely seeing the um the
industry change in the sense that
there's there's a feeling that you've
got to go big or go home
and you've got to scale to compete going
forward so you got to be in multiple
states and you've got to have chain
stores you got to have massive grows
and you got to be able to recognize uh
and get
you know efficiencies to mass produce
but
and i think that is true in a lot of
cases like eventually this industry will
be like any other one where there will
be
the massive producers whether it's you
know like the beer industry there's
those couple big names and now you have
the smaller ones
um as well that have a foothold but i do
think
you you have some businesses and right
it's all about finding your place
in the industry like in any industry and
so
some are absolutely finding a market
for that what we call a kind of craft
cannabis you know
a hand trimmed and and really
specialized and for the connoisseur and
it's not mass-produced
you know and just saying that can bring
a lot of people into the fold even if
the marijuana is this good
um so yeah it's there's there's
opportunities all over but everyone's
trying to find their place right now
and in some as we go forward that is
going to be the key to their success
who do you think's got it most right in
terms of dispensaries because i've been
to a med men
and man that was like walking into an
apple store that was insane
yeah i mean the thing is there's no one
right model because the consumer base is
so broad i mean you have
you have the traditional kind of hippie
stoner crowd right and they want a
certain look and feel and they don't
want it to feel like an apple store at
all that's a
they want that's the antithesis of what
they want and then you have
you know you have soccer moms and uh or
football moms
um and you have you know the people
professionals that are coming home from
work on a friday night
and they're grabbing an edible or
they're grabbing a pre-rolled joints
and uh instead of the wine or the beer
or maybe both
you know and so they want maybe that
apple store feel
um and then you have just the people who
are trying it for the first time
uh and they need uh they need an
environment where the store is
really outgoing and friendly and so they
just want to feel welcome and they want
to feel comfortable
and you know maybe an iphone type store
doesn't doesn't feel that way for them
so there's
it just depends on what your niche is
and who you're going for and what area
of the country you're in it really does
you know it breaks down sometimes
geographically and and this type of
store is going to work over here you
know
if you're in manhattan you know that med
men
iphone thing is cool and it's hip and
that's what you want you know
if you're in northern california you
know you want something that feels more
earthy or whatever you want to describe
i went to this one
captain jacks or something it was all
kind of exposed wood
on the walls and this was very it was an
independent dispensary uh
in san bernardino valley and it was the
weekend
of a big festival a music festival and i
think dead mouse was playing
uh so there's like fairly big queue
outside and i just decided to have a
little walk i had some work on the next
day and
i need to go see this because i've been
to the med men but i wanted to have it i
wanted to check this out
and sure enough the doorman at the front
because usually or at least in this one
there was a waiting foyer
so you have these people sat down are
you registered with us can you show us
your id there's a lady at the end
and you've got this huge african
bouncer at the front ju he was somewhere
between
a doorman and a hype man for a dj
so he's asking everyone yeah guys you're
gonna party this weekend
yeah yeah yeah like what are you gonna
get like hyped up and god
i couldn't believe it i was like this is
it was mind-blowing like it's just a
crazy experience to go into a place and
that was the waiting room
and then you go into the actual thing
and there's a bar set up
with um i don't know what you call it
where you put
a resin or concentrate into those
special type of bongs so and it was
there was a guy
doing special blends like a bartender
essentially behind this bar and there's
people sat down on these stools he's
like
so we we recently have this in we have
the sativa blend and we've got this this
thing
and it's mad it's so funny
well and then you go to vegas right las
vegas and you want a completely
different experience and you go
you go to one there near the strip it's
called planet 13. and that's like a
vegas dispensary you walk in
and they've got like this led floor
looks like you're walking on water
and then you get in and there's these
these circular drones every hour that
come out of the ceiling and they do this
like performance and they just oh
you know all synchronized they got
lights and you know that that that's
awesome too and that's what people want
when they're in vegas
that that may or may not work you know
in uh alabama [ __ ] did you see
i'm pretty certain it was in vegas i got
because i'm on med men's
uh mailing list and they send out an
email towards the start of last year
before kovid hit
saying if you land at is it mccarran
in yeah mccarran airport
we will pay your uber or we will
get a taxi to collect you from the
airport
to come to med men straight away
absolutely the the innovation in vegas
on this front is huge so yes
we have our mj biz con our big event
their
industry trade show global and when we
went one year
yeah med med had plastered that a lot of
the taxis without so the taxis
the cabs were red and they had med men
no way that's where
so people coming in the airport you're
seeing it all over town so
you know you're you're getting the best
and perhaps worst of american branding
expertise in in a city like vegas right
it's just in your face it's there it's
splashy
yeah some people love it but it you know
it works
what about scaling out now then how much
is the cannabis industry worth
sort of to america overall and then have
you got any idea globally
yeah i mean in the us we've seen
tremendous tremendous growth since 2011.
as i mentioned earlier 38 39 states with
medical
18th recreational and we have
billions of dollars on tap with new
markets that are launching new states
that have legalized recently but
in general you know we have we make
we've done our market research on this
industry for a decade and it's really
hard to pin down numbers because the
government doesn't track it there's
a lot of ways to look at it but so we've
honed our methodologies around the way
but
by our best estimates with a wide range
saying this is a more conservative view
this is a more
aggressive view you know is that sales
were
up to 20 billion 20 billion dollars with
a b
in a retail sale so that's through
dispensaries through recreational
marijuana stores
last year and we expect that to grow
about 30
this year and the growth was much bigger
in the past percentage-wise
but now our base is 20 billion right so
it's hard to double that
so 30 growth is massive for any industry
and you know that's billions of extra
dollars in sales
and uh we expect it to double by 2025
2026
um and and could even go higher again we
try and take a realistic conservative
view there's a lot of people just
throwing out numbers they're like look
at this and they make it look all shiny
we try and be careful um because we
don't want to steer steer people in the
wrong direction but
you know put that in perspective uh for
your uk audience i don't know how
familiar with some of this they are but
we the the current size the industry
that we expect this year
um already is well above the national
football league the nfl which is
massive here right that's we're all
based around the sport
in the u.s it's already well above that
and that's saying something
and it's actually catching up and we
expect the next couple years we'll
surpass craft beer
and that's another big industry that has
really exploded craft beers
is the beer situation in most of europe
but it's a you know
10 15-year thing here everyone used to
drink the cheap mass-produced beer
so that's a big thing it's it's actually
surpassing elements of the alcohol
industry
it's going to surpass the global opioid
market soon
so there's a lot of ways you can you can
look at this but
regardless it's becoming a big industry
in the us is it one of the top ten no
but it's it's huge what did kovid do
for the cannabis industry because i
imagine that a year ago
or maybe a year and a couple of months
ago everyone in the cannabis industry
was
squeaky bum time um it's what we squeaky
bum i like that
i'll have to use that um we you know in
in europe and a lot of other regions
there was kind of a slowdown a lot of
the legalization efforts there and
industries
uh and programs were kind of in the
formation stage or the early stages
so that kind of went way to the back
burner in a lot of other countries and
everything was kind of
more or less put on pause what we saw in
the us though
was this remarkable situation it's just
it's remarkable to me
this is one of those changes i mentioned
before that was immensely positive that
i could have never predicted
five six seven years ago and that we
have this pandemic that
shut down the entire world and
almost our entire economy and one of the
few
industries few types of businesses
allowed to stay open were
medical marijuana dispensaries and
in a lot of cases recreational marijuana
shops
and not every state went this route but
the majority of states that have
legalized
deemed these businesses essential during
a pandemic
i mean think about that this was a drug
i couldn't even talk about or was
nervous to talk about publicly 10 years
ago
and let people know i was in this
industry uh and i was worried about like
searching because we were doing a lot of
research and i was like i want somebody
to be tracking my internet and i'm
you know googling marijuana all the time
and 10 years later
it's deemed an essential business in a
global pandemic that has shut down the
entire economy
i mean so is what happened to answer
your question is
that move allowed the industry to thrive
they were allowed to stay open they yeah
they had to shut down in those early
days in march and april when every
everything was shut down but
they were able to resume sales and is
what you saw is
not only did they survive they thrived
and that's because
you had people sitting at home and and
the u.s was giving a lot of money
to people uh to not work without without
much to spend it on everywhere's closed
except for a few selected
businesses yeah yeah yeah order from
amazon order a bunch of stuff that
arrives at your door
and alcohol industry did really well too
as what we saw was cannabis did
really well not all of it right there
were pockets and there were certain
companies
but in general it's remarkable how well
it did and
uh you know people sit and it brought
new people into the fold that maybe
hadn't tried it
uh and we're like well i got nothing
else to do and it uh
you know uh current users tried
different products
um and and so you you saw
sales growth you saw record sales in
every state
and in some cases huge and even in the
mature states like colorado
and and i just want to make this point
when we first legalized recreational
marijuana here in colorado
there was a feeling among some that once
you legalize
if there's a novelty right and everyone
will start coming and then it kind of
wears off and you'll plateau at some
point
a couple years down the road as other
states start legalizing too
you know they're not just going to come
to colorado to do it and colorado hit
record sales
again last year and you know we're six
seven years into this and and and uh
more than a dozen other states have
legalized and have industries up and
running
so that didn't happen so that really
shows you the potential out there
in general uh for places in a for for
for anywhere in the uk in europe and
anywhere in the in the world
there's a massive market out there and
and it's on the medical side for sure
but it's also on that recreational side
so the industry did did fantastic
through the
pandemic all all else being relative
how does the recreational and the
medical
income compare so
it was i believe 2017
when recreational sales surpassed
medical for the first time in the u.s
according to our estimates and that was
just a couple years after colorado and
washington state legalized
and so is what you saw is medical was
the dominant because there was no
recreational and then it started slow
and now it is it's
uh you know three four times uh
maybe even more than that i have i'd
have to look at the numbers again but
it's massively bigger than the medical
the medical side is still growing and if
you were just to break out medical sales
you'd be like hey that's nice growth
like for an industry this is great uh
when you compare it to recreational
though it's it's
just a little part of the bar right um
and so uh we're seeing what we're seeing
is when states that have had a medical
industry up and running then legalized
recreational
within a couple years the patient
numbers start dropping
because it's just easier you know to go
to the store
buy whatever you want whenever you want
uh you might pay more
you often pay more in taxes uh but
you know the medical side starts to
diminish and even the the people who are
truly using it for medical
um you know they they don't want to have
to go see a doctor every year they don't
want to have to get a card
and carry around with them and so we
don't know the long-term future and if
these two are ultimately just going to
merge
into a cannabis industry or if there
will be a medical
component that's separate and separately
regulated and required has different
requirements
there won't be homogeneity across this
country
for many many years but eventually down
the road
it might develop into one singular thing
given the fact that the cannabis
industry overall
saw so much growth throughout 2020
how is it that i've seen an endless
number of videos on youtube
about how dan bilzerian and ignite
completely [ __ ] it with their accounts
well um i don't like to comment on
specific companies just because of what
we do with our journalism arm and our
events
um there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of things that aren't
going well
when you dive in uh look under the
covers there are
companies that are growing too fast
they're not
doing the right things they're making
bad decisions um you can look to canada
for this
you know canada the first g7 nation to
legalize recreational launched its
industry
and there was this massive rush into it
there's all this money and it's like
anything everyone's all excited and
and you lose your sense right even even
veteran business people you lose
your sense and so over investment bad
business decisions
um in some cases some sketchy business
practices
and um and you get caught in that hype
and we've seen it over and over in the
u.s when different you know
tech industry whatever and so um
that's what's happened and and that's
happening now there's some of the bigger
companies in this industry in the us
are poorly run um you hear a lot of
scuttlebutt in the background that
there's some potentially some shady
things going on
and um you know not not picking out
uh particular companies to say that
about but just in general
and there are there's bad decisions and
you look at the financials of some of
these companies you're like oof what are
you doing
what are you doing and they're getting a
lot of money what would you do if you
were to design a company a cannabis
company
that was going to fail what did what are
some of the things that you would
have it do it was going to fail yeah
um i would say you
jump at every single opportunity you see
which is very common
because there are a lot of opportunities
out there and everywhere you look you're
like
let's do that so if i was going to fail
i'd say hey let's go tackle this this
and this and this without a strategic
threat
behind them or the resources or the
know-how to do it right
um i would uh you know i would i would
play in the gray areas of the law
heavily
and uh you know take take shortcuts and
um and do things that you really are
that you really know
aren't appropriate or or even allowed uh
i would be um
i would also probably be a uh
untrustworthy trustworthy business
person who reneges on deals or
who tells you want things or who makes
uh an acquisition
and promises all this stock and and
everything and then it just
disappears for the owners these are the
types of things we see
and and doesn't always mean they're
failing the companies but
these practices are out there and really
not understanding the market
or or i just come in with my experience
in some other industry
and be like i know how to do this i i
don't need to listen to these cannabis
people like i know how to do this
i've done it successfully in another
industry so i'm just going to do it this
way and
they're they're all silly they don't
know what they're talking about it does
that's a quick route of failure it does
feel like a different beast
it's different what uh have you looked
much into the potential for a
psychedelics
industry so yeah i've been focusing on
that more recently
um and it's a tough one because
my opinion on this is i don't know the
business potential yet
so if you're looking at it from a
business side i don't know what this is
right now there's money being pumped
into it sizable money in some cases
hundreds of millions of dollars
into in some cases publicly traded
companies
in canada uh or in the us that are doing
research or they're
you know it's one of these where
sometimes you don't even know what the
company's doing
just says psychedelics and people are
like cool um
so it's hard for me to understand the
market at this point i'm looking into it
more
and we are as a team but one of the
things that strikes me
is the cannabis industry is quickly uh
latching on to this
in in not just in the us in canada
in europe all over you're starting to
see cannabis
companies talk about psychedelics and if
i start at the base level
i have to question and i don't have an
opinion
on this yet but what is the crossover
like should cannabis companies be
leading this charge maybe
because it comes from similar you know
it's a drug it's an illegal drug that's
coming out of the darkness and
and there and it's a plant in many cases
it's based off and you're extracting
things
so and there's medical parts to it so i
see that i see the reasons why companies
are doing this but i don't know if it's
the right thing
like um you know is there enough
crossover that cannabis companies can
can enter this or do this effectively i
don't know
i mean should this be a health care
thing should this you know is there
something else
um so it's part of me is a little
puzzled and i don't know if it's the
right route for cannabis
to be leading this charge although i
understand why
and so you know again identifying what
the crossovers are
and so for us when i talk about how do
you fail
you go in a million different directions
right ooh psychedelics now i'm going
here this is a perfect example
so we as a business and how i try and
run mj biz
you know we we have to figure out does
this fit with what we're trying to do or
is this the shiny new object
that we go chase and for our business
are we going to have an event on it
are we going to have a lot of coverage
or we have a newsletter
maybe but this is an example of how you
can go down another path that may or may
not have to do with what you're doing
now
so i don't know where this is going i
think there's potential here
and look when we started in 2011 as i
said
people were like what the hell are you
doing with marijuana like this is crazy
you know where you closet pothead
and you're starting this little you know
magazine
and uh and so i i always catch myself
and say you can't
view things like that because i could
easily say that about psychedelics now
and say really
okay mushrooms come on and we used to
joke at mj biz daily we used to say
hey one day we'll have magic mushrooms
daily as a joke like five years ago
um so i don't know where we're going
with that but uh
but there's a lot to unpack there have
you registered the domains just in case
no get them registered chris come on
come on you know how to head your bet
it's 10.99 on godaddy or something get
them right get them registered
finished up on here i think i think
there does seem to potentially be a
a bit of a difference between the
cannabis industry and the potential
psychedelics industry
in that the potency of the drug and the
potential effects
are magnified fairly significantly
it's the difference between having
half a spliff and having one to two
grams of mushrooms
is fairly profound and
i don't think it's the sort of industry
if it gets to the stage where it's
recreational use of magic mushrooms i'd
be very very surprised
i think it would be therapeutic use with
guidance
because as anyone that's taking
psychedelics knows set and setting are
very important
and if you just let someone wander in
and uninitiate
go into some store somewhere med men's
uh
psychedelics wing they go into the
genius bar at the back and they say well
we can try this and you can try this and
try this
the aftercare that you need with
psychedelics
is significantly greater than it is with
weed
um i don't know enough about weeds to
know how big of a difference setting
setting makes i imagine it would make a
bit of a one
but nowhere near as much there's a it's
a power law right it's it's a
real sort of magnifying effect when you
do have psychedelics
so i would be surprised if we see it end
up being fully recreational
but the therapeutic effects seem to be
outstanding so well especially
especially if you can
do what they do with with cannabis now
and you can extract the
certain elements out of it and and get
to a point where you're not
you don't have the you know um
psychotropic effects that you're it's
not affecting you that way but there are
health benefits so
there's a lot on the health side that's
that's exciting to explore
i mean i agree with you on the
recreational side i can't see that
developing like the marijuana industry
did but if you asked me 10 years ago
don't use marijuana i'd have a beagle
and you could walk into a store and see
gummies and chocolate bars and bath
bombs and
you know jars of weed that you could
just go in and buy it and then put it on
the seat of your car and drive home and
not worry about getting arrested
i would have never thought that either
what are the
craziest iterations or the funniest or
most interesting iterations of delivery
mechanisms for weeds that you've seen
um i i mean you know there's
suppositories
that's is that really well that's on the
medical side and it has a medical uh
uh purpose yeah um
you know i i don't have any really
really good examples
um i've seen some topical ones right
this
subdermal things that you rub on your
skin but
your skin can absorb it and you can
still get some psychotropic oh yeah
um yeah topicals are big that you put on
your skin uh they're not huge part of
the market but they're appealing to some
people so that's all out there
you know there's there's products out
there to enhance your sex life
uh gels and and creams and other things
that
i can't do much when i use your
imagination hi when i'm high i can't do
much i don't want to use
it as in some sort of like pre-pre-bed
warm-up routine
for some people it works um apparently
so there are products there are products
out there for that
okay there's a yes product out there for
you for that um
so yeah i mean i think that's where the
innovation is people are just
saying these companies are saying what
what can i use this in
tell you what i was really impressed by
while i was in austin i had
some one and two milligram
thc mints and i thought that that was a
really
cool subtle way
to integrate thc
into a into a routine yeah absolutely
and and you go into these stores and
again the
the product selection is vast i mean
it's it's mints
it's lozenges it's lollipops you know
it's gummies it's chocolate bars it's
cookies it's all the baked goods
um now they've got you know powders that
are water soluble and you can put them
into any drink
and you can put you could sprinkle it in
your seltzer water
or you put it in your beer if you wanted
to yeah
yeah yeah i don't know if you'd be
working out much
just be sitting in the corner on your
phone um but you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of interesting things out
there and you know beverages is another
one that's gaining some traction it's
not a big part of the market but
you know you can buy you can buy infused
fruit punch and sodas and
and teas and uh you know
it goes on and on now i mean basically
anything out there is a
a consumer product that can be ingested
i think people are experiencing
they're experimenting with what's the
future of the cbd industry because i've
heard you on other shows talking about
there's not just cbd there's cb n
cbm yeah there's a there's a there's a
lot of other
components that have not really been
explored yet so cbd is the one that gets
a lot of the headlines
and is the big industry focus and um
that was kind of i think because it was
the easier one that people had
identified and that we kind of started
rallying around that as an industry but
um you know cbd is an interesting one
that it a lot of the countries that have
legalized medical cannabis
outside you know the us and canada
they're essentially cbd
programs um they're called medical
cannabis but there's not a lot of thc
the stuff that gets you high
in them um cbd is interesting because i
don't know where it's going to go i
think there's
there's been a huge um groundswell of
interest
from consumers from companies all across
the world and
i think there's a lot of people who feel
it gives them benefits there's not a lot
of science on it
so it's hard to say does this really
help you or do you think it helps you
but i absolutely think it does help
people for different things
you know whether it's sleeping or just
relaxing reducing anxiety
there's a lot of there's a lot of areas
that need to be explored
uh into how this interacts with our
bodies but a lot of people
in in the us you walk into a convenience
store your neighborhood
market and there's you know little cbd
oils or these
lotions and um and then you can get cbd
heavy marijuana strains
and there's a million products out there
now i don't know
if this massive demand will wane and
when
you know is this going to be like some
other additive or ingredient
to things that we use every day maybe
you know does it become
uh you know we've had these fads i'm
sure you've had them you know
probably in different areas in the uk
but fish oil and everything got fish oil
in it for a while or echinacea
yeah the thinking is is this going to be
like that i don't know
but i think there's a lot of benefits to
it i'm i'm bullish about its potential i
don't know where
the ceiling is or how how it'll all
evolve but i absolutely think
i've known many many people who have
used it um for
for pain relief even use rub it on sore
muscles and stuff so
there are a lot of uses have you got any
concerns about long-term use of cbd
given that we don't have
longevity real extrapolated out studies
in terms of time spans
i mean you know i guess that's the case
with a lot of things
we don't even really have that with
marijuana in a lot of cases i mean we do
have studies of course but
it um not a lot of funding globally
behind
really researching that so i'd be more
worried about the thc
side and i'm not overly worried about
that anything
that you um eat you know you eat too
many carrots and you uh you know your
skin turns orange you drink too much
water you could die right like so
you know i think in moderation um
you know they're they're fine i don't i
don't personally and i'm not giving any
health advice
um i'm not personally worried about like
over consumption of cbd and my long-term
effects of everything i know about it
um so i you know thc
i mean developing brains teenagers
probably
not a probably terrible thing right and
i don't know what it does to regular
users over 40 years um you know you
might need to want to be a little bit
more cautious with that but same with
alcohol right same with coffee
same with chocolate it's interesting
making the comparisons especially
between weed and alcohol
i think the hypocrisy is so flagrant and
obvious
that it's almost uh kind of cliche to
bring it up right it's so
it's so trite to say that well look at
the way that people go about
treating alcohol a substance which
causes so many more externalities
that are super negative and we have
there's this study from the landsat
which you may have come across or not
that the the single line summary was
there is
no safe level of alcohol consumption
the couple of things that people used to
say that you get which was some
resveratrol and
a couple of other unique types of
vitamins and minerals that could be
derived from red wine
was offset by the increased chance of
heart failure
and of the negative externalities so
even the one thing or a couple of the
things that
were touted as potential benefits are
negated and then further offset
into the negative uh by that and yet
you can see within the pushback from the
more conservative side or from people
especially in the uk you know that we
don't have the same
weed culture in the media at kind of the
top down
and then emergently from the community
bottom up either
you know we don't have a thingy and
thing you go to white castle we don't
have that kind of
stoner world over here so much
so when you're talking about the fact
that it might take a little while for it
to break
the uk that doesn't surprise me
yeah i mean i mean it might uh but you
know i i
and i know the uk is a lot different
than germany in germany you know you
walk around everyone was already smoking
it everywhere
um i don't think they have that cultural
side either though of
it's uh yeah that's glorified here it's
it's um
so yeah i mean it's again it's hard to
predict how quickly things could change
um and uh you know i i wouldn't be
surprised to see you guys go in this
direction
sooner rather than later some people in
the uk need it desperately yeah
where should people go they want to keep
up to date with marijuana news
yeah go to mjbizdaily.com and that's our
main
website where we cover the industry uh
internationally
and uh with a focus on the us and canada
and then
from there you can get to our
information for our big conference
mj bizcon coming up in october getting a
lot of international interest in that
again i think
everyone's hoping the barriers to travel
will
fall and that we'll all be in a much
better place with covid
in the us things are looking really good
right now and then uh i also started a
podcast seed to ceo where i talk about
for new people coming in the industry
here's here are some
you know lessons learned from those who
are in it here's the things you need to
know about here's success stories and
case studies so you can get to all that
through mjbizdaily.com
what's the podcast seed to ceo yep i
love that that's cool
nice man chris walsh ladies and
gentlemen chris thank you for coming on
man
thanks for having me on have fun thank
you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy peace
you